de notre sommet de l'otan et du g7 que
nous venons de tenir
ici même avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues et faire un point aussi de
situation en effet un mois après le
déclenchement de la guerre la russie
contre l'ukraine où en sommes nous le
peuple ukrainien mené par son président
a résisté déjouant
les calculs de la russie d'une victoire
militaire rapide
nous avons avec nos alliés nos
partenaires européens répondu avec
fermeté réactivité et unité là aussi
déjouant les pronostics d'une réponse
faible et divisée
et donc nous continuons de nous tenir
aux côtés du peuple ukrainien avec un
soutien militaire économique humanitaire
l'europe a déployé une capacité
d'accueil sans précédent qui reviendrait
pour les plus de trois millions et demi
de réfugiés d'ores et déjà sur notre sol
et notre détermination nous a conduits à
prendre un train de sanctions absolument
inédit à l'unisson
l'économie russe est d'ailleurs au
moment où je vous parle en cessation de
paiement sa monnaie a dévissé son
isolement est croissant et notre
pression ira s'accentuant en cherchant
là aussi
par tous les moyens d'obtenir un cessez
le feu et la paix
ces initiatives que nous avons lancées
se poursuivent et il y à quelques
instants la résolution humanitaire
portés par la france et le mexique a été
voté à une très large majorité à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
avec 140 voix pour et simplement 5 voix
contre ce qui montre l'isolément
maintenons
de la russie en effet la russie a pris
une responsabilité historique en lançant
cette guerre et notre stratégie donc de
bien tout faire pour pouvoir stopper
toute escalade mais cesser le plus
rapidement le conflit par notre soutien
le cren nos sanctions et les discussions
que nous poursuivons à quelques-uns avec
le président poutine pour pouvoir
trouver les voies et moyens d'une
solution négociée le sommet de l'otan de
ce matin a permis d'acter plusieurs
éléments d'abord une 1e unanimité pour
continuer de renforcer le soutien à
l'ukraine lui fournir les armements
défensifs les matériels dont elle a
besoin président céline ce qui s'est
adressé à nous à cet égard a fait de
façon très nette part de ses besoins et
au fond la ligne reste la même pour
l'ensemble des alliés continuer à
fournir des armes défensives et létal le
faire dans un cadre
d'efficacité
complète mais avec une ligne rouge vous
le savez qui continue de ne pas être
comme belligérants c'est aussi pour
cette raison que je n'entrerai dans
aucun détail mais avec le chancelier
allemand d'autres européens nous avons
aussi insisté sur l'importance dans ce
cadre de continuer à oeuvrer pour une
voie négociée crédible le deuxième
élément qui ressort de notre sommet
c'est la nécessité de dissuader toute
escalade du conflit sans jamais donner
le moindre prétexte aux arguments bien
connu et très souvent employée par la
russie pour les provoquer l'otan a fait
un choix qui est de soutenir l'ukraine
pour arrêter la guerre sans faire la
guerre comme je le disais et donc là
aussi nous avons décidé d'intensifier
les travaux et ils sont en cours et déjà
commencé pour prévenir et les scénarios
d' escalade et évidemment nous organiser
en cas d' escalade
enfin nous avons acté de la nécessité de
poursuivre l'adaptation de notre posture
à la nouvelle donne stratégique provoqué
par la guerre en ukraine et ses
conséquences à ce titre je veux dire
combien la france est au rendez vous de
la solidarité pour assurer la sécurité
de nos alliés du nord au sud du flanc
oriental la carte qui vous est ici
présenté vous permet de voir manière
très claire l'ensemble de nos
engagements actuels qui ont été donc
renforcé ces dernières semaines
en norvège qui était un exercice prévu
la france est comme vous le voyez un
très grand contributeur puisque nous
avons trois mille deux cents militaires
engagés et donc nous avons sûr que le
réponse response et un engagement fort
et je veux à cet égard redire toute mes
condoléances
à l'endroit des états unis d'amérique
suite au décès des quatre militaires qui
ont perdu la vie dans le cadre de cet
exercice en estonie nous avons décidé de
maintenir notre présence et de la
renforcer donc nous avons environ 350
militaires comme vous le voyez ici avec
des missions donc qui ont été renforcés
puisque nous y tenons d'ores et déjà
présent nous avons monté notre
contribution terrestre et avec également
des missions aériennes
ou la france donc participent à ces
missions de police du ciel pour le
compte de nos amis baltes
au dessus de la pologne dans le sud-est
de l'alliance nous avons aussi renforcé
notre présence comme vous pouvez le voir
le choix qui a été fait dès le début de
contribuer au dispositif aérien en
pologne et jusqu'au sud de l'alliance
notre volonté de contribuer y compris à
travers les missions qui sont les nôtres
à un dispositif aérien de vigilance ce
qui justifie la présence en particulier
du groupe aéronaval mais également de
nos capacités au large de la bulgarie et
de la roumanie pour pouvoir déployer
donc ce que nous continuons de faire
l'ensemble des moyens nécessaires donc
surveillance également de la bosnie à
partir du groupe aéronaval et puis et je
dirais encore plus le choix que j'avais
annoncé dès le début d'année au
parlement européen avant ça dans des
voeux aux forces armées de pouvoir nous
engager dans le cadre de la nrf
550 militaires français avec la
contribution de plusieurs autres états
membres et la france est une nation
cadre dans cette opération en roumanie
qui a vocation à monter en puissance
dans le ft avec la belgique et les pays
bas et donc vous le voyez du nord au sud
la france est aujourd'hui un
contributeur concret de notre alliance
et du réarmement stratégique européen
que j'avais appelé de mes voeux devant
le parlement européen tout ça montre
aussi la cohérence de l'action qui est
la nôtre c'est à dire une volonté
d'avoir une europe de la défense et une
europe qui prend ses responsabilités et
c'est la démonstration que cette europe
de la défense est bien une composante de
l'otan et en aucun cas ni un substitut
ni un concurrent et je crois que ces
dernières semaines ont pu crédibiliser
le message que nous n'avions cessé de
marteler la complémentarité de ces deux
ambitions
nous avons travaillé aussi ces dernières
semaines et nous aurons l'occasion tout
à l'heure de poursuivre en européen et
d'acter l'adoption de la boussole
stratégique qui nous permettra ensuite
de préparer une position commune à
l'otan et le sommet de madrid qui vient
tirer les conséquences de l'exercice
stratégique que nous avions lancé en fin
d'année nos 1019 lorsque j'ai vu
l'occasion moi même de lancer le débat
et d'indiquer qui me semblait important
que nous puissions
réorganiser nos efforts stratégiques
airs concevoir notre stratégie au sein
de l'alliance donc tout ça arrive à
maturité dans un moment évidemment où
notre nous sommes collectivement tester
franck la meilleure réponse à ce test
est à la guerre lancée donc en ukraine
et la réponse que nous sommes en train
d'y apporter
le sommet du g7 a quant à lui complété
cette réponse à d'autres égards d'abord
sur le plan des sanctions par une
coordination très étroite j'ai dit nous
avons répondu de manière très rapide
avec plusieurs trains de sanctions 4
paquet de sanctions qui ont été prises
de manière très coordonnée dès le
deuxième jour suivant le lancement du
conflit
et nous avons constamment répondu en
européen en alliés mais le g7 a été un
instant ce de coordination très
importante et ces quatre séries de
sanctions ont été parfaitement
coordonnée et nous avons décidé un
mécanisme au sein du g7 de suivi de ces
sanctions qui permettent la transparence
de la bonne application des sanctions
prises pour éviter qu'il y ait des
divergences entre les différents membres
ce qui affaiblirait la cohérence du
groupe mais pour aussi mesuré mettre en
commun nos listes d'oligarques soumis à
nos mesures faire travailler ensemble le
ministre des finances et de la justice
pour aller au bout de la mise en oeuvre
des décisions et préparer évidemment les
décisions à venir si celle-ci s'imposer
et nous sommes tout à fait prêts à
accroître évidemment ces sanctions à
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire
nous avons aussi apte et de mobiliser
collectivement pour à l'égard de
puissances amies qui sont pas forcément
autour de la table du g7 ou de l'otan ni
membre de l'union européenne pouvoir
relayer ces sanctions soient pour les
faire adopter ce que nous avons tenue de
plusieurs autres soit au moins pour
limiter les stratégies visant à aider la
russie à compenser nos actions l'analyse
que nous faisons tous c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces sanctions ont un
impact j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
difficultés financières économiques de
la russie c'est un pacte est tangible et
il nous faut le poursuivre pour avoir
cet effet dissuasif
deuxièmement nous avons défini un agenda
de solidarité entre les membres pourquoi
pas ce qu'il y à une asymétrie dans les
conséquences que la la guerre fait peser
entre les membres du g7 comme d'ailleurs
entre les membres de l'otan qui suppose
une solidarité d'abord en matière de la
gestion des réfugiés
l'europe de manière logique par
géographie est la première contributrice
et s'il ira entre 6 et demie et 7
millions de déplacés aujourd'hui
ukrainien il y a d'ores et déjà trois
millions et demi d'ukrainiens et
d'ukrainiens qui sont sur le sol
européen
c'était l'un des plus grands défis que
l'union européenne a à vivre depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale et je
pense en particulier aux pays qui sont
les plus impactées parce qu'ils sont
voisins de l'ukraine et nous devons en
plus évidemment avoir une solidarité
pour d'autres pays qui sont nos membres
de l'alliance ou l'union européenne mais
encore plus touchés je pense à la
moldavie ce qui nous a conduits à d'ores
et déjà mettre en place des stratégies
de réinstallation comme nous l'avons
d'ailleurs fait la france a pu en
conduire elle même ces derniers jours et
donc ce que nous avons demandé à nos
partenaires du g7 c'est d'être
solidaires et de pouvoir en lien avec
les européens continentaux quand il
s'agit des britanniques des canadiens
des américains des japonais nous aidé en
lien aussi avec le hcr et les nations
unies a mené ces opérations de
réinstallation et à pouvoir partager
cette solidarité c'est d'abord un
élément donc très concret pour nous tous
et puis c'est aussi ce qui nous
permettra de lutter de manière efficace
contre toutes les formes de trafic
humain et de bien protéger en
particulier les familles les enfants les
femmes qui sont aujourd'hui soumises à
cette situation que nous connaissons le
deuxième élément de solidarité c'est la
solidarité énergétique
l'europe est là c'est une
caractéristique aussi naturel et notre
géographie et le plus grand acheteur
de fossiles parce que nous ne sommes pas
producteurs
et donc nous avons cette dépendance en
particulier au gaz au pétrole au charbon
russe notre souhait est évidemment de
d'abord maîtriser les prix pour nos
consommateurs nous y reviendrons tout à
l'heure au conseil européen mais de très
vite diversifiée pour moins dépendre et
ne pas être soumis à des mesures de
représailles mais surtout nous mêmes
réduire
les éléments
d'achat qui aujourd'hui vont vers la
russie est donc cette sortie de notre
dépendance au pétrole et au gaz russe
passe là aussi par une diversification
de nos achats et une politique concertée
avec les autres membres du g7
certains membres peuvent augmenter leur
production d'hydrocarbures certains
membres peuvent aussi nous aider dans
une stratégie de diversification
c'est ce que nous avons acté aujourd'hui
avec un rôle tout particulier des états
unis d'amérique et du canada qui sur ces
énergies fossiles évidemment une
contribution importante et avec lequel
nous voulons renforcer nos coopérations
pour réduire nos dépendances c'est pour
moi un élément très important tout ça
est complémentaire de notre stratégie de
sortie des énergies fossiles qui et je
dirai est notre premier choix le plus
structurant par cohérence avec notre
stratégie climatique
simplement nous savons que tout ça prend
du temps et donc dans ce temps un
intercalaire il nous faut diversifier et
c'est là où là la stratégie de
coopération au sein du g7 est
essentielle enfin je voudrais insister
sur ce point dernier élément de
solidarité est une solidarité
alimentaire
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises mais l'ukraine comme
la russie sont de très grands
producteurs en particulier de céréales
et aujourd'hui nous en vivons les
impacts en europe nous avons des
tensions sur les prix nous avons aussi
des tensions dans plusieurs filières qui
ont conduit la france et deux européens
réagir avec les plans de résilience par
exemple pour aider nos éleveurs qui sont
très dépendants des tourteaux venant
d'ukraine pour nourrir leurs bêtes et
avec un renchérissement des prix se
faisant de production pour nos éleveurs
et parfois de risque de rupture nous
sommes en train d'y pallier néanmoins
d'ores et déjà nous sommes tous
confrontés à une hausse des prix mais
aussi et surtout
nous sommes en train de rentrer dans une
crise alimentaire sans précédent parce
que d'autres pays proche et moyen-orient
afrique sont eux très dépendant pour
nourrir leur population
de ce qui est aujourd'hui produit en
ukraine et russie
la guerre en ukraine et les choix qui
ont été faits par la russie gravissime
et responsable et je le dis bien c'est
la conséquence directe des choix de la
russie et de la guerre font que des pays
comme l'égypte mais plusieurs autres au
machrek au maghreb en afrique au proche
et moyen-orient ont aujourd'hui des
difficultés à s'approvisionner en blé
plus largement en céréales pays comme
l'egypte dépend à 80 % de ses
importations de la région ukrainiennes
et russes et donc à court terme il y
aura des difficultés dans ces pays mais
surtout la guerre en ukraine rend
impossible pour le moment par le choix
fait par la russie de ce mets comme il
se devrait et donc est en train de créer
une situation qui sera encore plus grave
dans 12 à 18 mois
cette situation va créer une crise
alimentaire des situations humanitaires
gravissime dans plusieurs pays et à coup
sûr des conséquences politiques massives
dans plusieurs des pays que j'évoquais
face à cela nous ne pouvons rester
impuissants je veux ici vous alerter et
donc il nous faut réagir agir par les
actions que nous conduisons est donc
dans les échanges que j'ai avec le
président poutine durant lesquelles
comme vous le savez j'appelle à un
cessez le feu rapide je plaide aussi
pour qu'il puisse y avoir et je le redis
ici solennellement à la russie la levée
des restrictions à l'exportation sur les
denrées alimentaires la possibilité
laissée
justement de semer mais il est
absolument impérieux que au delà du
cessez le feu la russie se montrent
responsables et ne prennent pas en plus
justement cette responsabilité de créer
cette famine qui sinon est à coup sûr
inéluctable mais nous faut aussi réagir
en construisant justement l'avenir et en
mobilisant nos céréaliers nos semences
yeno transporter nos assureurs
l'ensemble des acteurs internationaux
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité au nom de
la france et en tant que président
justement du conseil pour ce semestre au
niveau européen est en lien direct avec
l'union africaine je me suis entretenu
il ya quelques instants avec le
président macky sall lancer une
initiative comparable à ce que la france
avait pu lancer au moment de la crise
sanitaire avec l'initiative acta
le but de l'initiative que nous
souhaitons lancer nous avons décidé avec
le président macky sall d'appeler food
and agriculture résilience mission donc
l'initiative farm a pour but de tout de
suite nous organiser main dans la main
avec les pays concernés les
organisations compétentes comme avec le
secteur privé lancé une initiative pour
pallier cette crise avec d'abord un
pilier commercial pour apaiser les
tensions sur les marchés agricoles
élaborer un plan d'urgence de libération
des stocks en cas de crise pour éviter
toute situation de pénurie et modérer
les hausses de prix plusieurs pays sont
en train de continuer à constituer des
stocks il est indispensable de manière
concertée de libérer ses stocks au plus
vite d'obtenir aussi un engagement
multilatéral à ne pas imposer de
restrictions à l'esp à l'export des
matières premières agricoles vous
retrouvez des situations très comparable
à ce qu'on avait vécu sur les produits
de santé au moment de la crise qu vides
il y a deux ans et mettre en place un
suivi transparent des obstacles au
commerce des produits agricoles et des
prix sur les marchés en s'appuyant sur
le système d'information sur les marchés
agricoles mises en place
lors de la présidence française du g20
ce premier pilier commercial évidemment
sera travaillé en lien très étroit avec
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
nous avons eu l'occasion de préparer
cela avec sa directrice générale un
deuxième pilier de solidarité à vocation
pour nous a préparés aux premiers effets
de la guerre dès cet été avec une action
coordonnée des pays producteurs pour
relever temporairement les seuils de
production lorsque cela est possible et
sans compromettre les objectifs de
durabilité et de mettre en place un
mécanisme d'allocations des volumes pour
garantir un accès de tous en particulier
les plus vulnérables en quantité
suffisante et à prix raisonnable
c'est un mécanisme qui l'a aussi
s'inspire très concrètement de
l'initiative acta que nous avions lancé
en réponse aux vives 19 ce qui veut dire
très concrètement
pour nous européens
assumer de produire davantage en
respectant nos normes en respectant nos
règles en étant très vigilant sur les
sujets climatique et de biodiversité
mais en réhaussant les cons objectifs de
production qui sont les nôtres pour
contribuer à cet effort de solidarité et
un troisième pilier enfin en faveur de
la production dans les pays les plus
concernés en augmentant
significativement les investissements
dans la production alimentaire durable
et les chaînes de valeur agricole
résiliente sur tous les continents et en
intensifiant nos opérations pour
permettre aux pays qui sont les plus
dépendants des importations
de la zone russo ukrainienne de produire
davantage sur leur sol et là c'est très
cohérent avec ce que nous avons relancé
en janvier 2021 avec vous souvenez sans
doute la grande initiative de la grande
muraille verte où l'initiative sur les
protéines végétales que nous avons
accéléré sous présidence française
initiative qui ont vocation à lancer des
opérations de déforestation de
développement agricole dans les pays
justement allant de golf de guinée
jusqu'à la corne de l'afrique et de
manière très concrète en leur permettant
de produire davantage sur leur sol voilà
une initiative que je souhaitais ici
vous présenter je les expose et angers 7
pour engager les collègues autour de la
table qui sont tous des grands pays
producteurs
et je pense que nous devons être
exemplaires en terme justement de
capacité à produire là aussi davantage
le ferai tout à l'heure dans le cadre du
conseil et nous élargirons évidemment
dans le cadre du g20
tout cela se faisant main dans la main
avec l'union africaine et avec
l'ensemble des pays les plus concernés
voilà les quelques éléments que je
souhaitais vous apporter en compte rendu
de sommet de l'otan et justement de ce
g7 et l'annoncent aussi je souhaitais
vous présenter cette initiative
française en matière de sécurité
alimentaire
question kamil colin de tf1 s'il vous
plaît
président j'ai une question centré sur
les entreprises françaises qui sont
implantées en russie on a vu que renaud
suspendait son activité sur place l'état
est au capital de renault mais d'autres
font le choix de rester leroy merlin
auchan ce qui amène à une certaine
confusion sur place quelle est la ligne
que vous vous défendez est le message
que vous pouvez adresser à ces
entreprises qui sont pointés du doigt
par les autorités ukrainiennes merci je
vais être
revenir aux fondamentaux de notre action
notre objectif et par tous les moyens de
stopper la guerre et donc d'avoir des
sanctions qui sont efficaces en touchant
les secteurs les plus sensibles et les
personnalités les plus sensibles mais
évidemment de limiter les impacts sur
nos économies
il y en a néanmoins et donc nous
veillons à les corriger c'est pourquoi
nous avons concentré nos impacts sur les
instituts bancaires la banque centrale
qui a été sans doute l'une des actions
les plus décisives que nous avons menées
et les oligarques et il ya d'autres
types de sanctions qui peuvent se
poursuivre sur des secteurs stratégiques
qui pour l'ensemble des européens et des
alliés sont évidemment plus sensibles
charbon pétrole gaz mais que nous
n'avons pas pris pour le moment dans ce
contexte là
je souhaite que toutes les entreprises
j'ai même demandé explicitement à ce que
toutes les entreprises françaises qui
opèrent dans des secteurs sous sanction
avec des partenaires sous sanction que
ce soit actionnaire ou partenaires
industriels
respectent ce que la france
décide et actes et c'est ce qui est
aujourd'hui fait par tous les acteurs
français à côté de cela il y à des
pressions qui sont faites il ya des
risques réputationnel pour des
entreprises qui opèrent en russie hélas
ma position et de laisser libre les
entreprises de décider pour elles mêmes
c'est le choix des dirigeants de ces
entreprises de d'apprécier en fonction
de leur équilibre en fonction de leur
activité
de faire les choix qui convienne c'est
le choix qu'a fait renault c'est le
choix qu'ont fait d'autres entreprises
de cesser certaines activités je
considère que nous la priorité ça doit
être l'effet final recherché qui est
justement de stopper l'action russe
voilà le manière très claire la position
de la france je considère ensuite que
dans la durée
ses choix de toute façon doivent être à
chaque fois évaluer parce que quand une
entreprise plus qu'on le mesure décide
de tout arrêter en russie elles laissent
des salariés elle laisse une emprise qui
de toute façon continue à tourner est ce
qu'on fait plus souffrir la russie
et ses dirigeants je ne suis pas sûr je
me pose juste ça sur la table parce que
ça veut dire que ce sont des capitaux
russes qui roule récupère cette
profitabilité
donc je pense que ce qui est important
c'est à chaque fois d'être cohérent dans
nos actions renault a fait un choix je
le respecte d'ailleurs l'état français
en tant qu'actionnaire ne s'est pas
opposé à ce choix il était cohérent à la
stratégie et ils s'inscrivaient dans une
appréciation de la situation je crois
qu'ils étaient celles de l'entreprise
jérôme rives l afp
je reviens sur le sommet de l'otan alors
est-ce que vous pensez que l'otan doit
apporter une aide militaire sans
restriction comme comme l'a demandé le
président cnce qui ce matin
si oui est ce que la france compte
augmenter ses fournitures d'armes
aller à l'ukraine alors je sais que
voulait pas dire lesquels mais d'autres
pays sont beaucoup plus beaucoup moins
discret que vous
et est ce que vous êtes entendus lors de
ce sommet sur des lignes rouges en cas
d'utilisation d'armes chimiques
alors sur la première question il y a
une limite je les dis qui est de ne pas
devenir co belligérants cette limite est
partagé par tous les alliés est donc
très clairement livrer de nouveaux
équipements
en particulier avions hochart
aujourd'hui personne ne la franchit
parce que il est évident qu'elle
caractériserait une co belligérance par
contre beaucoup de
matériel militaire
peirsol antichars ont été livrés depuis
le début de la guerre et continueront de
l'être par les alliés
d'autre s'ils continuent d'honorer des
contrats qui précédait le déclenchement
de la guerre et continue d'aider
l'ukraine donc il a été acté que nous
continuerons cet effort avec la même
cohérence et avec les mêmes limites
et je pense que c'est ce qui permet
d'ailleurs de contribuer à tenir
à côté de ça sur la deuxième question
que vous avez posé je serai très prudent
sur ce sujet d'abord parce que ce qui me
concerne à chaque fois que j'ai eu à
définir des lignes rouges je voulais
être parfaitement sûr que les définir
avait un effet dissuasif et que leur
franchissement serait suivie d'effet
est-ce que je considère que c'est comme
ça que la parole de la france ou de
total y est respectée c'est ce que nous
avons fait en avril 2018 lors de
l'opération hamilton je pense qu'en
l'espèce
l'ambiguïté stratégique et la discussion
et la discrétion sont plus efficaces
donc je m'en tiendrai à cela nous nous
préparons nous menons des travaux mais
je ne m'explique citerai pas aujourd'hui
quelques lignes rouges sur ce sujet